[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar driving lab efficiency with pcr
power i am sabrina lemoos of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask question
box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
please note we will be distributing poll
questions throughout the webinar your
participation is greatly appreciated
i now present today's speaker kyle
hondorp the senior product manager
thermal cyclers and plastics thermo
fisher scientific and maria navascapte
the product manager dna polymerase
thermofisher scientific
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen maria and kyle you
may now begin your presentations
thank you sabrina for for the
introduction
um and welcome everyone to today's
webinar
driving lab efficiency with pcr power
there are three objectives that we aim
to achieve with this webinar
one
is help you to discover ways to get the
most from your pcr and improve lab
efficiency
two understand key aspects of critical
pcr components and instrumentation
and three learn how to avoid common pca
mistakes and troubleshoot pcr issues
when they arise
here is the outline of today's webinar i
will start with a brief background about
pcr
then i will talk about ways to enhance
your pci productivity how to design
ideal primasco pcr and my colleague kyle
will continue talking about
instrumentation and plastics for pcr
so let's begin with a brief background
polymerase chain reaction or pcr is a
molecular biology method used to amplify
or multiply dna
pcr works even from a single dna
molecule each amplification
cycle consisting of template
denaturation primer annealing and primer
extension steps
during each cycle each dna copy is
increased two-fold so for example
after the second amplification round you
will have four copies of the same dna
after the 30th cycle 10 to the power of
nine copies of the same starting dna
so this is a really powerful technique
to study dna and
and its analysis
pcr needs several components to work
there is of course a dna polymerase that
synthesizes a new strand from a primer
by incorporating nucleotides
all these components are mixed in a
special plastic plate so or tubes
which are then loaded to the thermal
cycler to begin cycling protocol and we
will review most of these components in
more detail in today's
the webinar
let's begin from from dna polymerases
at any polymerase synthesizes a new dna
strand and there are several
several activities that are important
for pcr
synthesis of the new strand relies on
five prime to three prime polymeric
activity
and all polymerases process this
activity
another
is three prime to five prime exonuclease
activity which removes
misincorporated nucleotides
dna polymerases with this activity are
commonly known as proofreading enzymes
because it helps to ensure sequence
accuracy during amplification
and these enzymes are commonly used in
applications that require
a high fidelity
pcr
polymerases possess other activities as
well
that are important for pcr
processivity
is a measure
of of a number of nucleotides
incorporated by the enzyme
in a single binding event until the
enzyme dissociates from the
template this activity is also related
to the enzyme's affinity or how tightly
it binds to the template
high perceptivity of enzyme contributes
to faster dna synthesis
higher inhibitor tolerance and ability
to amplify longer dna fragments
another property
hostart
helps ensure higher specificity and
sensitivity
dna polymerases can be active at room
temperature while polymerases with hot
start mechanisms
are not
these enzymes are activated during
denaturation step at high temperatures
ensuring that amplification
begins only in a thermocycler
giving you a specific
amplification only
now let's take a look at how hot start
enzymes can help increase your lab
productivity
amplification of non-specific dna
fragments is a common pcr issue
it can be caused by room temperature
reaction setup because any polymerases
are somewhat active at room temperature
this is a problem as primers might bind
to non-specific targets and give rise to
unwanted
unwanted pcr products
similar to what you see in lanes
two and three of
in the gel image
on the right
this can be avoided if the reaction is
set up on ice but still enzymes activity
is not fully inhibited
an easiest solution to avoid this is to
use a hot start enzyme which is modified
to be inactive at room temperature
the hotpot modifier
it can be antibody chemical after body
or aftermer in any case the reaction has
to be heated first to activate the
enzyme
remove the modifier and enable synthesis
of the new dna strand
this way a hot start enzyme provides
better specificity and yield in pcr
which can be seen
in the
fourth enzyme lanes
in the gel image on the right
if you are using a proofreading enzyme
blocking three prime to five prime
exonuclease activity is especially
critical
non-hot start proofreading enzymes or
proof eating enzymes with suboptimal hot
start mechanism
can have lower
sensitivity and specificity
especially when working with high
complexity dna like human genomic theory
and this is because the exonuclease or
the proofreading activity can degrade
primers or templates even before the pcr
starts and
as you can see an example in the image
on the right
to prevent this
you can use a proofreading enzyme with
syringe and hot start mechanism that
blocks both polymerase and proofreading
activities
and this enables detection of low
concentration targets and amplify
specific bands
now if you set up pcr using liquid
handling or robotic platforms
stability of assembled reactions at room
temperature is critical to achieve
optimal results
hot start modifications of pcr enzymes
makes this benchtop stability possible
and if you use astringent hot start you
can achieve
stability for
up to 24 hours
as you can see in the gel image on the
right
uh the same result was obtained when pcr
was ran after this setup and when it was
left for
24 hours at room temperature
if you are looking for a hot start
enzyme
our in vitrogen platinum pcr enzymes are
designed with antibody
platinum hotstar technology
these antibodies fully inhibit enzyme
activity until their initial
denaturation step
which means greater target yield
sensitivity benchtop stability and
ability to set up reactions at room
temperature
and now let's move on
and talk about
high fidelity pcr enzymes
polymerases can be defined by the error
rate that they make
the error rate of an enzyme is defined
as
the number of incorrect nucleotides per
total nucleotides incorporated it can
range from one in millions for high
fidelity enzymes
to one in thousands for low fidelity
if you compare error rates or or
fidelity information for different dna
polymerases it is important to keep in
mind that there are different ways to
measure fidelity
and the results can vary significantly
there are three commonly used methods
to measure fidelity that are shown here
on the slide
so on the left there is a colony
screening assay
anger sequencing in the middle and on
the right next generation sequencing
so when comparing fidelity of different
polymerases it is important to note the
method that was used
and only compare values that were
measured using the same methodology and
best if measured under the same
conditions
now collin is creating athletes and
sanger sequencing both require
huge amount of data to estimate
statistically significant and reliable
error rates of high fidelity polymerases
nowadays next generation sequencing
enables analysis of large amounts of
data and simplifies quantification of
statistical data
in this example in the graph
fidelity of dna polymerases was measured
by next generation sequencing
the values were normalized to tags in a
polymerase
so here the value indicates how many
times fidelity of the proofreading dna
polymerase is higher compared to tac
measurements for these polymerases
indicated in the graph were made side by
side under the same conditions allowing
accurate comparison of the results
and let's look at how high fidelity
enzymes can improve your lab
productivity
if you do cloning or sequencing any
sequence accuracy is critical
you want to minimize possibility of
having an error in the pcr sequence
and this is where it is critical to use
a high fidelity polymerase
if you are to choose a pcr enzyme with
the highest fidelity possible
that will increase your confidence
in the dna sequence accuracy after
amplification and save and save your
time from troubleshooting and repetition
of the experiment
displayed on your screen is our first
pull question
what kind of issue have you experienced
while performing pcr
a
incomplete or no amplification
b poor sensitivity and or specificity
errors in pcr amplicons
c contamination or d other
we will now look into pcr enzymes with
high processivity and how it can
simplify pcr when working
with challenging samples
as was mentioned before processivity is
defined as the number of nucleotides
incorporated
by the enzyme
in a single binding event
to the dna template
the higher the processivity the more
nucleotides the enzyme can incorporate
without falling off
the strand
this often leads to faster synthesis
rate
and increased enzyme affinity to the
substrate
so how can a higher processivity of an
enzyme help in a daily pcr
if you amplify dna from inhibitor rich
samples like plants
blood or soil
you may have difficulty with your pcr
this is typical because pcr inhibitors
are not completely removed during dna
purification
in such case if you use highly
processive enzyme you can come you you
can overcome pcr inhibition because
these polymerases tolerate suboptimal
reaction conditions
you can see an example here shown on the
right where dna samples were amplified
with spiked known pcr inhibitors
using highly progressive platinum to
attack dna polymerase
it is often a challenge to amplify long
beanie fragments for example longer than
10 kilobase
success rates often low there is high
error rate and long cycling
in such situations high fidelity enzyme
with high processivity can simplify the
workflow
because the enzyme ensures low error
rate and better amplification of longer
fragments while high processivity of the
enzyme leads to shorter cycling time and
also increases success rate of the
amplification overall
ah the gel image on the right side
shows amplification of 20 kilobases
from human genomic dna and even up to 40
kilobases from e-coli genomic dna using
our high-fidelity platinum super phi 2
dna polymerase
gc rich dna amplification
is another common challenge in pcr
gc reach regions are harder to separate
and
we can form secondary structures after
the separation
most often additives like dmso
are used to overcome these challenges
also there are specialized enhancers
available with some enzymes that
simplify reaction optimization
now our latest platinum superfine 2
enzyme
comes with an innovative buffer that
allows amplification of gc-rich targets
without a need for an enhancer bringing
down
all the optimization efforts to a
minimum
and in the next section i will talk
about some some other ways
uh how to increase efficiency
when doing pcr
and one way is
to choose
direct pcr approach
which enables pcr without prior dna
purification
cutting down
the workflow time significantly
the conventional pcr involves dna
purification which can take from an hour
to several hours depending on the method
direct pcr does not require this
and you can get from sample to pcr in
less than an hour
in addition
theref pcr is handy when working with
very small samples as it requires many
minimal handling and minimizes chances
to lose
the sample completely
it is also an ideal choice when working
with many samples in high throughput
labs for example
for
genotyping experiments
displayed on your screen now will be a
second poll question
would you like to receive a quote at an
early stage of your research
and for our third and last poll question
would you like to be contacted by our
sales support team to help you make a
purchase
now the uneating temperature for primers
often needs optimization
to help ensure efficient binding of the
primers
to achieve
the best result
it is a long uh serious process
especially if you work with multiple
primer sets
however our latest
platinum pcr enzymes are formulated with
universal primer annealing
temperature
these enzymes allow you to use a 60
degrees
annealing temperature for different
primer sets
you can see
an example on the right
where all
all dna fragments were amplified at 60
degrees
while their actual calculated melting
temperatures
ranges from 59 to 69 degrees
this universal annealing feature
provides two additional benefits shown
here
first you can amplify
multiple different length fragments in
the same run
or using the same 60 degrees annealing
temperature
and using extension time of the longest
fragment
as depicted
in the image on the top
fragments up to 5 kilobases can be
amplified without losing specificity or
yield
what this also means is that
different pcr assays can be cycled
together
using one thermocycler as shown in the
bottom image
typically with other enzymes different
pcr assays need to be run sequentially
or on different instruments so really
universal primary annealing
significantly saves time when it comes
to
reaction preparation
and also a cycling step
and lastly i will
just briefly summarize how to choose a
right enzyme
based on your application
if you need
to detect a target sequence just
basically get a yes or no answer
or use a low fidelity enzyme
for example platinum two tags in a
polymerase
now if you need to preserve dna sequence
accuracy in applications like cloning
with sequencing or mutagenesis
high fidelity enzymes
like platinum super phyto
will benefit you
if you want
to detect target dna from samples
without purifying dna
choose platinum direct pci universal
master mix because that will save you a
lot of your time
and down at the bottom
there is a link where you can find more
information about our platinum enzyme
family
and now primers primers are essential
for pcr
so let's look at some tips how to
simplify your pcr by designing good
primers
if primers were not designed correctly
you will either get
no amplification or lots of non-specific
products
it is essential to follow primary design
rules
to design primer for optimal results
here on the right you can see several
tips to keep in mind when designing
primers
that is a primer length gc content
number of dinucleotides or repetitive
bases
these are just some of the aspects to
consider when
designing a new primer pair
or
you can use the specialized tools for
private design where you do not really
need to think about these rules and
one example would be
a oligoperfect primer designer online
tool
and now my colleague kyle will continue
talking about
thermocyclers and plastics
thank you very much maria for all that
wonderful information
beyond the selection of appropriate
reagents and primers to improve pcr
efficiency
instrumentation also plays a critical
role in driving pcr success
it is important to select a thermal
cycler that ensures precise temperature
control
thermal cyclers that deliver
inconsistent temperatures
can impact the accuracy of pcr results
especially if seeking a specific
annealing temperature
or performing pcr optimization protocols
this can lead to confusing results and
require additional time to re-optimize
protocols to overcome this
one way to achieve the solution is to
look for a thermal cycler that provides
precise temperature control
a traditional gradient temperature
control
allows you to set a minimum temperature
on one side of the block
and a maximum temperature on the other
side
heat then transfers across the block in
a gradient
but it lacks temperature accuracy at any
specific well
there are technologies available
that allow for precise temperature
control
the veriflex block technology
temperature control technology
utilizes
blocks constructed of metal segments
each segment contains its own heating
and cooling elements
depending on the instrument
you can find either three or six
independent temperature zones
with the ability to uniquely
control each zone
you're able to achieve accurate
temperature control which is ideal for
enzyme studies
restriction digests
or any workflow requiring temperature
precision
if your lab is limited with the number
of thermal cyclers available
this can create backlogs and scheduling
and delays and time to results
today there are thermal cyclers with
very basic features
and small footprints
available at a reasonable price
this makes it easy to obtain
personalized instrumentation
allowing more lab members to have access
to their own benchtop thermal cyclers
one of the challenges many researchers
face when switching to a new model of
thermal cycler
is the ability to transition protocols
to the new instrument without needing to
re-optimize experiments
thermal cyclers can operate using
different ramp rates
this makes it challenging to replicate
experimental results across instruments
to solve for this
look for thermal cyclers that offer
simulation mode
simulation mode provides a library of
instrument modes
that mimic the ramp rate of those
instruments
this makes it easy to transition
protocols and workflows
without the need to reoptimize
simulation mode is available on applied
biosystems thermal cyclers
another way to improve pcr efficiency
is having the ability to manage pcr
protocols and runs while away from the
lab
look for instruments that offer secure
remote access with a wi-fi or
cloud-enabled instrument
securely connect through your mobile
device or desktop computer
to start or stop a run
design and share protocols
or export data
this gives you greater control over your
research
whether you are in the lab or working
remotely
one area to improve pcr efficiency that
is often overlooked
is the selection of optimal pcr plastics
to fit your instruments
thermal cycler manufacturers design
thermal blocks and instrument lids to
fit either a limited or wide range of
pcr plastics
plastics that don't fit the thermal
block can lead to deformation
or crushing
causing sample of aspiration or loss of
results
to solve this use the manufacturer
recommended plastics designed to fit
your pcr or qpcr instrument
you can find recommended plastics by
using manufacturer compatibility tables
or use free online pcr plastic selection
guides to confirm the fit of the plastic
with your specific instrument model
at the bottom of the slide you will find
a link to an online plastic selection
guide for plastic compatibility with
applied biosystems
and other instrument manufacturers
pcr tubes are available in a variety of
sizes and formats
how do you select the right fit
first you need to know the profile of
your thermal block
are you working with a standard 0.2 mil
block
or a 0.1 mil also known as a fast
thermal block
the tubes are different sizes
to fit the appropriate block style
so make sure you select and know the
blocks format that you're working with
for the best fit
the second consideration is what style
cap do you need
domed caps are used in endpoint pcr
and can help absorb lid pressure and
prevent tube crushing in instruments
with inner concave lids
flat caps are recommended
for instruments that have a flat lid
an ultra clear cap are used when working
with real-time pcr instruments
for experiments that require additional
throughput we recommend the use of tube
strips
dupe strips are available with either
eight tubes or twelve tube
you can find two strips that come with
tubes and caps separately
or to prevent cross contamination
we recommend using tube strips with
attached cap
this will allow you to independently
open and close each tube as you're
working with that particular sample
again use compatibility tables or online
selection guides
to make sure that the plastic is the
right fit for your thermal cycler
ccr plate selection also depends on the
instrument
lights come in a variety of styles they
can be non-skirted
semi-skirted or also known as half
skirted
or full skirted
automation usually requires a semi or
full skirted plate
while non-skirted plates offer more
flexibility to fit many thermal block
formats
the applied biosystems thermal cyclers
use semi-skirted plates
deck style is another consideration
a flat deck offers the most universal
fit with instrument lids
and is also compatible with automated
heat sealers
raised decks are plates that have a
plastic lip that goes all the way around
the outer edge of the plate
this is required to help balance lid
pressure on certain thermal cyclers
and is required to fit with thermal
certain certain thermal cycler lids
finally when should you seal with caps
versus film
cap strips can be used for both tubes
and plates
they must fit securely and seal tightly
in order to avoid evaporation
film is often used when working with 96
or 384 well plates
and foam has the advantage that it can
be cut into smaller sizes
to fit segmented plates containing 24 32
or 48 wells
adhesive clear film or adhesive oil can
be used in endpoint pcr
while optically clear film is
recommended for real-time instruments
optically clear film is a pressure
sensitive film
and requires pressure to be applied to
form a proper seal
for more information about forming a
proper seal we do recommend the use of
an adhesive film applicator
when using the applicator you apply
pressure gently and evenly across the
rims of every well to ensure that the
adhesive
deals with the well to prevent any
sample loss
other ceiling considerations may include
considering the deck of the plate
especially if you're wanting to use an
automated ceiling method system
or the type of lettering do you need
raised or engraved lettering to ensure
you get a proper seal
for more information about any of the
pcr workflow topics we have discussed
we have assembled some resources
we have a pcr workflow solution brochure
that goes through various
portions of the pcr workflow
you can also find more information on
our product pages for our pcr enzymes
thermal cyclers or pcr plastics
you can click the link to get access to
our pcr application notes
we also have a pcr education webpage
that will discuss considerations for pcr
as well as common troubleshooting tips
links to our various brochures and
handbooks
will help further your understanding of
the pcr workflow and the products
available to support your research
our hope is that this webinar provided
you with helpful insight to drive your
lab efficiency with powerful pcr tools
designed for speed
simplicity and accuracy
i thank you for your time today
and now maria and i will be happy to
take any questions
thank you maria and kyle for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question
do i still need to use the universal
annealing temperature i trust in healing
temperatures i calculated
oh thank you for the first question
um
the answer is uh no uh you don't have to
use universal primary annealing
temperature
uh the enzymes will work with the
calculated temperatures
as well
but the universal kneeling feature
is convenient when you are working with
multiple primer sets
wonderful the next question i have
how do i get samples of the enzymes you
mentioned
i thank you for the question uh yes so
to get the samples please contact our
therma fisher sales representatives
and in some countries you can also
request product samples directly
on our website
wonderful the next question i have what
type of pcr plastics do you recommend if
i am automating some of my workflow with
a robot
that's a great question
there are actually two factors to
consider when thinking about using
plastics for robotics
the first one will be the skirt type as
i mentioned before semi-skirted and
fully skirted plastics are usually
recommended for automation
that's important because the robotic
grippers or paddles that move the plates
around will need some surface in order
to do their gripping
the second consideration is the pcr
plastic material
some plates are prone to warping and
cannot work well within automation
automated processes
therefore we would recommend plates that
are constructed with a stronger
polycarbonate frame which resists
distortion caused by those robotic
grippers
and tolerates the robotic transfer well
those plates still contain the same thin
walled polypropylene wells that are
traditional in all pcr plastics but that
frame makes an important difference
and for thermo fisher scientific we have
both the endura plate and the armadillo
options for polycarbonate frame plastics
thank you so much the next one i have
do your thermal
cyclers have gradient capability
great question
the pro flex verity pro and simply amp
thermal cyclers feature our veriflex
block technology so this is that precise
temperature control
the instrument either contain three
or six segmented metal blocks
each with their own heating and cooling
element so that each zone can be set
with a unique and independent
temperature
our verity pro instrument also has the
ability to set temperature based on the
minimum and maximum temperature across
the block
or to set the midpoint which is our zone
three range of the thermal block
thank you so much
the next one i have fidelity value that
you showed in the graph
does look different from what i see on
my enzymes manual can you explain that
that's a great question thank you
yes correct
fidelity values
can different it can differ
depending on the methods used in
measuring and so different companies
will show different values for their
products
as it was mentioned during the webinar
for example
if values were measured using the lac
based method
it will vary significantly compared to
values measured using
next generation sequencing
and this is especially true for
uh for higher fidelity enzymes where you
really need to use a sensitive mesh
method to measure fidelity accurately
the bottom line though is when comparing
fidelity values of different enzymes
they should be measured side by side
using the same method under the same
conditions
wonderful thank you
we have time for a few more here
do you have direct kit for rna
uh yes we do have a direct kit for rna
we recently launched
a new kit it is called superscript for
cells direct
it synthesizes
the cdna directly from
rna of cell samples
thank you another question tell me more
about wireless connectivity
yes cloud enabled instruments
allow you the freedom to design and
securely upload your methods
monitor runs or check instrument
availability from any mobile device or
desktop computer
you simply need to look for an
instrument that's wi-fi or cloud enabled
and connect to it
great
and how can i prevent sample evaporation
during pcr
great question proper sealing of your
pcr reactions is essential to preventing
evaporation and sample loss
if you're using an adhesive film you
want to make sure that it properly fits
the size of the plate and to align the
cover across all wells
adhesive film will stick
an optical film does require its
pressure sensitive and requires pressure
but in both cases we do recommend the
use of the adhesive applicator tool to
firmly press across the entire film and
to make sure that the rims of every well
are securely connected and sealed
you can also use cap strips with plates
so if you're not getting a proper seal
that's another option is to consider
using cap strips as long as you ensure
that the cap strip has a tight fit in
with the plate
so those are a few suggestions on how to
properly seal
thank you okay let's see here the next
one i have can the choice of hot start
modifier make a difference
oh that's a great question thank you
now my short answer would be
yes
there is a difference and it mainly
depends on your application
so for example
antibody modifiers
are quite stringent and can fully
inactivate the enzymes
but antibodies are proteins so they not
mean so they may not be suitable
if your application
requires low protein concentrations
a chemical modification
modifies the enzyme
so the enzyme
that is
that has a chemical hot stars may not be
uh fully reactivated during the
activation step
uh which quite often impacts the
amplification of log sequences and
sometimes enzyme sensitivity
and then uh antibody and asthma
so these are small
molecules uh they're not proteins
but they may not be as
stringent
uh depending on their dissociation
temperatures
thank you so much
and the next one i have
direct pcr sounds great but what are its
drawbacks
oh it's a good question
um so one thing to keep in mind with
direct pcr is that you are not actually
purifying dna which is
which is good if you don't need it but
uh if you need a purified genomic dna
for a certain downstream application
then a direct pcn may not be
a good approach for you to use
the next thing is that a sample size
is important
because if you add
too too little
or you may not get any amplification the
signal will be too low or if you add too
much of your sample
it will inhibit the pcr reaction
um we do have some
uh guidelines
on our website
uh how much of samples to add depending
on on the sample type and depending on
on the protocols are used for direct pcr
wonderful i have two more questions here
premier design rules look complicated
i've seen some tools on the web any that
you would recommend
uh yes of course uh we recommend is
using our free
online tool called oligoperfect designer
the design rules are built into the
algorithm
so you don't really need to
think about all those rules
and
we also recently updated its bulk
ordering function
to simplify the ordering if you have
many primer pairs
perfect and i have one more question
that we're going to wrap up with do i
need to measure fidelity of the enzyme
that i am using
no you don't have to measure a fidelity
of the enzyme that you are using it is a
really tedious process
and
usually the enzyme suppliers
do that for you
wonderful thank you again marie and kyle
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time thank you again maria
and kyle goodbye
you